[Music]
it's like this show is just spiraling
and spinning into so many new cool
things how does that feel it's very cool
and it's nice because there's a lot
happening in the world and so to be here
in celebration of culture of Arts it's
definitely better than spitting into a
spiral of Twitter and what's happening
in Charlottesville right now it's hard
to ignore that that happened I mean how
are you feeling after this weekend and
did you talk to any of your cast members
about well I was just with them and I
think we're all in this kind of strange
state what is happening in
Charlottesville it's such an example and
the personification of paint in a way
that hasn't been seen in such a long
time we've had these instances
throughout the years and what you see on
our black men being killed or whatever
the situation is in which we are aware
of the racism that still exists what you
see an entire rally and protest centered
around the idea of an entire race being
inferior and centered around this idea
of hate that's also and saying but it's
one of those things where what I do
appreciate is that everybody is more
United
and I think it is hard for anybody to
ignore the idea that racism is still so
prevalent and relevant and everything
that we do it's a lot to take in and I
know you're working hard to be such a
great example for everybody what are you
most excited for in terms of what's next
for you next what we start to spin off
September 5th is the actual start date
and I'm excited because talking to Kenya
talking to the writers we're really
looking forward to like being real to
the teenage experience it's gonna be
relevant and real and I'm excited for
Zoey to grow up and I'm terrified so
anything else you can tease for I mean
honestly though he gets in trouble
that's all I can really say
[Music]
you